la très jolie fille qu'on va accueillir
maintenant à traverser l'atlantique à la
rame en solitaire 5000 km 800 mille
coups d'aviron
voici les débouchés
comment ça va très bien avec vous vous
êtes magnifique l'a vraiment les shadoks
pompey et puis il touchera mère à mère
ramène qu'il revienne à la télé les
chats ne peut le savoir
on ne fait pas la prépa le savoir vous
est traversée de l'atlantique à la rame
en solitaire comme je disais 800 mille
coups d'aviron 49 joueurs 49 jours c'est
un virage en tête avec 40 est dans le
désert 40
elle a fait 49 marchés beaucoup ramé
lambda sur le pied vous publiez un
journal de bord
c'est la promo ça vous publiez un
journal de bord qui s'appelle ma
victoire sur l'atlantique
voilà je le montre la caméra comme on
fait intelligent voilà zoom tout ça oui
c'est ça votre bête il s'appelle une
barque récession c'est un bateau pas la
gueule de son bateau yakut est quand
même un paquet le bateau ben ça coûte et
combien l'histoire américaine 850 mille
francs ouais c'est pas très cher
après je sais pas quand il avait 6 ans
communication impressionnant alors sa
soeur au cherche midi donc là on s'est
tous sur la traversée passé le monde que
là tu peux aller à travers la première
traverse une partie graphique et on a
donné un petit peu moi j'essaie de
donner un petit peu juin ton jeune
dynamique et qu'est ce qui est sympa et
côté féminin car sort alors vous l'avez
écrit ce bouquin par téléphone c'est ça
avec votre la politique il avait écrit
bombe à six mois après mon arrivée en
guadeloupe et la 2e ou s'ils étaient
tous les deux jours on faisait un
quasiment ben on life
je faisais mes petites confidences est
on vraiment d'une main voilà
non j'ai amélioré y êtes allé voir mais
une main toute façon j'adore dans mes
écrits si ça abîme la télé un matériau à
cela au bout de 15
[Applaudissements]
or dix points dont vous êtes né à evian
ce des 26 ans 10 habiter dans une
ambiance vous a été levée dans une
ambiance familiale assez favorable à ce
que vous faites parce que vos enfants
vos parents pardon ce faisant elle me
trouve le long métrage est le trou petit
poucet ouais c'est ce qu'elle a fait vos
parents vous et faire des excursions des
machins et vous bougez vos parents quoi
il oui oui ils ont toujours été là quoi
pour l'homme du veille aussi bien joué
dans le regard il habitait à evian il
vous faisait déjà du bateau sur le lac
des viandes de bateaux du voilier
montréal et surtout à la montagne et je
crois que j'ai mes parents ont toujours
été là pour pour favoriser un petit peu
notre temps visite à ma soeur et moi et
alors ses parents donc enfin les parents
de peggy vos parents avaient une espèce
de deux vices comme ça qui est très joli
tir et de femmes de vis de sénèque qui
était punaisée au dessus de son lit et
peggy évidemment un jouet l'appliquer
cette devise et des parents étaient
moins content la devise c'est ce n'est
pas parce que les choses sont difficiles
que nous n'osons pas c'est parce que
nous n'osons pas qu'elles sont
difficiles ça c'est beau sauf qu'un jour
elle l'a utilisée pour elle elle leur a
dit je vais faire un peu moins content
ça vient c'est l'atlantique en solitaire
donc j'avais fait des études des petits
boulots mais j'ai eu ben oui après mes
études après cinq ans d'études
j'ai travaillé j'étais ingénieur
logistique chez alcatel démission pour
faire une traversée de l'atlantique à la
voile
une expérience de la haute mer et après
ben reboulleau parce qu'il fallait bien
payer s'est retrouvé en train d'éplucher
des légumes
oui pendant trois jours ça m'arrivait
parce que j'avais pas d'argent pour
payer mon téléphone la recherche de
sponsors ya des pages c'est vrai mais
juste avant de partir et je suis allé
dans une boîte d'intérim fribourg valais
nous faut de l'argent immédiatement
qu'est-ce que vous avez bomba des
légumes mais je me suis retrouvé à
commencer à enfin me lever à 3 heures du
matin pour commencer à 4h et éplucher
les brocolis l'attenté que ça c'est ce
que je me suis dit exactement
c'est terrible et c'est vrai que les
femmes qui font que ça sent très bien
montré courageux alors le rêve est venu
comment en voyant florence arthaud
joseph le guen la bobine enfin tous ces
conférences arthaud c'est vrai que je
vais trouver sa route du rhum fascinante
et par la suite oui c'est en fait la
traversée d'aboville parce que j'ai vu
que j'avais vu à la télé et j'ai trouvé
ça facile en effet de voir que la force
du caractère et ce formidable leçon de
courage que c'est tellement fou il
offrait pour atteindre son objectif et
je me suis dit pourquoi pas moi
et le jour vous avez décidé il ya bien
un jour vous ai dit voilà je vais y
aller c'était quand je dis voilà jean à
quel moment on dit tiens ça pourquoi pas
moi et après le moment on this que je
pars tout seul et ce que je pars à dieu
et puis moi ou osi bon maintenant oui je
suis dans cette can a mis pas mal
d'emmerdements la performance bon là je
perds sur la performance c'est pour
prendre l'avion c'est dur de trouver un
sponsor par exemple voyez c'est
compliqué alors première une faute
d'abord une première tentative donc vous
avez la grande canarie à la guadeloupe
est le cas nous ça arrive à deux jours
de l'arrivée de ces peluches arrive mais
sa niche arrive c'était le cpdc vrai que
tu vas regarde dans les yeux et regardez
dambach été fermé je pose une question
donc la première traversée le bateau
chavire à deux jours de l'arrivée de sam
est bon toi maman réponds moi j'organise
tout alors c'est ça oui non un jour
avant d'arriver un jour avant en plus je
dinkle et il ya eu problème de
recommencer c'est ce que j'ai recommencé
dont vous étiez cammas est en colère
vite j'avais comme un alien dans le
ventre oui ça et j'avais une somme je
sois vraiment le sentiment de cette
première d'ailleurs c'était une victoire
inachevé et le fait de se dire qu'on a
passé la première fois 79 jours en mer
par corus amis km et la de xavi est 130
km très bien alors on va regarder
maintenant on a un petit magnéto avec
des images de votre votre exploit
l'exploit de peggy bouchet magnéto serge
de partir malgré les quelques faudra
chercher la petite musique à l'intérieur
dans ma bulle
bah moi je l'avais promis je m'imagine
fait mouche et sa bande à olivier
m
à chaque fois que je vois les images de
l'arrivée ces mouvements oui mais vous
aviez rêvé votre papa en tous les cas
bravo progrès bravo bien ici alors
l'espace à bord c'est quoi ces deux
mètres carrés non c'est ça oui de mètres
carrés mais pas toutes habitable quoi il
ya de nous il ya de l'humidité à 95 %
d'humidité
donc ça veut dire que la nuit et de la
compensation elle vous est réveillé par
les gouttes d'eau qui vous tombe sur la
figure regardez comment on va vous aviez
donc votre matériel
vous aviez un livre de d'aboville ce qui
était bien parce que ça non pas que je
veuille en fait déjà vingt deux sortes
de bouquins gorce et les bouquins
d'humour genre les pensées de sacha
guitry hasard voilà et l'autre côté
j'avais des livres d histoire vraie
c'était les femmes en prison un
commissaire est la mucoviscidose un
petit peu a bondi à vous dire comme
c'est ta chance
il n'a rien touché au bras vous aviez
des disques décédé
vous aviez golman bon ça encore mais
indochine comment est-ce qu'on peut
traverser l'atlantique avec un disque
d'indochine ça c'est pas aussi vite et
dans la première traversée vous aviez un
poster au plafond avec cinq mecs jean
torse nu à ses beaux mecs mais c'est des
copains qui m'aide à faire dans la
deuxième
pas de photo pas de photos alors la vie
quotidienne s'est passé comment une
journée c'était commencé été enlevé en
même temps que le soleil et premier coup
d'oeil bon déjà pour enlever la
condensation de la bulle et pour voir un
petit peu l'état de la mer et le premier
coup de fil système routeur à pire la
nuit pour voir un peu la tendance de la
journée et bu un petit couteau
de jus de fruit et ensuite brin de
toilette les crèmes solaires le stick et
j'étais parler pour les avirons pendant
10 heures avec une pause toutes les deux
heures j'ai vu que vous et pilier les
jambes et ça c'est bien vous tenez à
être mais je crois que c'est important
parce que bon j'aime bien voir dans les
duels king qui en me voir à avoir quand
même une image et c'est correct je pense
que c'est important de se respecter même
quand on est tout seul je regrette
maquiller le soir de noël si oui j'avais
du récit là mais je me change sur le tee
shirt les deux jours et en portant haut
pour prendre des douches faisait comment
les gras des grands oui métier tout nu
sur le bateau voilà mais bon c'était
rageant c'est que je m'étais dit que
j'attendais que le grain passe à côté
d'un classique
l'alcool c'est vrai que buviez deux
apéros par semaine
ah oui j'aimais bien deux apéros c'est
pas la même
mais je redis du monde les personnes
venaient me voir mais ténue du v10
justement je vais vous poser la question
qui tue maintenant peggy bouchet est ce
qu'on peut faire la lumière de la
question qui tue sexuellement ça se
passait commande sur ce bateau c'était
difficile
sérieusement ça vous a manqué non je
crois que quand on fait beaucoup
d'efforts comme c'est comme ça et puis
non on n'y pense pas trop
non mais c'est pas une partie de
rigolade quoi c est ainsi qu à la rame
donc c'est c'est cas de le dire c'est de
la galère tous les jours c'est des peurs
ses des souffrances est bon tout ça on
n'a pas le temps passer au reste on met
la ville marie vous avez lu je
n'arrivais pas insisté jeudi soir et
corrections marque met de pression je
suis parent dont on m'a dit tu vas voir
à l'émission d'ardisson qui va pas être
très sympa il va passer j'en ai même pas
parlé
c'est vrai on est un petit peu mais
c'est sept ans j'ai connu plus pointu
que ça n'arrive pas à parler d'un bien
et la nourriture alors parce que vous
n'avez pas le courage de tuer les
dorades il parle ah oui je vous parle du
poisson vous avez peur des boissons
c'est vrai ah oui mais le même le petit
poisson volante qui grand comme ça je ne
peux pas du chèque les doigts donc je
prends un tee shirt de la veille et je
le prends pas sa nouvelle maman ça c'est
bizarre d'aller traverser l'atlantique à
la rame en solitaire mais encore des
poissons une volonté métier quoi 25
centimètres au dessus de l'eau eh bien
il ya des creux comme un comédien 6,7 m
qua non pour trois étages
ah oui c'est la trouille moyer les jours
où j'ai une peur viscérale et là quand
il y avait
des crues de cet auteur ne veut pas
sortir de la cabine puisqu'on peut pas
un peu de parent ami donc on voit les
vagues qui arrivent par l'arrière et qui
passe par dessus tout c'est vraiment une
héroïne non mais c'est vraiment
quelqu'un je sors du kata la balise
argos et tu dis je vais je vais pas la
mettre en action mais se disait ça y est
des fois un défaut de didier cuche a
glissé on se dit on a de quoi on a un
médecin quand de la balise on this et
dans les moments difficiles c'est
tellement difficile tellement facile
d'aller l'autre côté et d'appuyer sur un
bouton
enfin bon moi je me suis dit je me suis
pas l'élite toute cette peine soit la
zambie zanis j'étais ballotté d'un côté
à l'autre par les vagues s'est couverte
de bleus n'ont oui oui c'était un
véritable shaker à l'intérieur jeu
d'origine le carré avec des peluches du
papier scep a enfin quelque chose
c'était des aliens dans le ventre après
savoyard vous criez tout seul de nuit
oui c'est des crises de larmes m'arriver
comment voyez-vous quand je vais sortir
qui avait 2 3 mètres de creux dans une
sorte d'exutoire que je sortais je me
mette à crier pour rendre qui peut
évacuer toute cette peur et toutes ces
souffrances mais ce qui la nuit c'est
terrible l'intérieur
le quotidien belge
quand d'être en fait ça les regarde les
outils le requin trompette c'est les
arts tente de loin et le cargo de se
prendre un carton plein et une histoire
terrible avec ce cargo l'ailé qui a
voulu violer l'argent pas le cas les
marins du cargo
oui un chalutier qui m'a accosté et
c'est vrai que la bomba je reste et je
savais pas quel était leur attention
donc la cia c'est terrible ben j'ai eu
peur à la fois le droit ça s'est passé
donc j'avais dix marins que maguy marin
bord et puis moi cost est bon moi je
pouvais toucher leur coque avec ma main
et ils tapaient sur le bateau quoi je me
suis dit encore un pet et ça y est ce
débat est coupée en deux mois je suis
une passe qui cargo s'il dit les gars ça
fait deux trois mois qu'ils sont une
petite glande date exacte
10 c'est un petit four
ça se mange sans faim ça ressemble ségou
tiff
c'est bon ocado et là tu as fait quoi tu
as appelé tanoh j'ai crié j'ai crié pour
gardiens sont barrées ils n'ont pas
voulu les mecs mais c'était pas un
moment où tu attends d un arbre puis
mieux en plus de l'atlantique
j'ai visité sévère de la deuxième jour
de l'apéro le jour de l'épi laferrière
réveil a dit gaga ne s'est pas préparé
risée sur pas compris comment pourquoi
ils sont repartis
moi je sais pas ça a duré dix minutes et
leur crier dessus a cité les noms et
puis elle a dit non ça n'avait qu'une
minute et c'est légal sont demandeurs
depuis un moment sa part que ça dure
jamais longtemps
nettoyez le bateau est alors vous
finissez par arriver donc normal quand
même le 5 janvier à la martinique
alors quand on vous dit à quoi ça sert
vous dites ça a valeur d'exemple déjà
parce que ça montre que dans la vie on
est on est toujours seul et que de façon
inutile de d'envoyer sans arrêt des
balises de détresse que finalement la
l'on doit la message pour les jeunes
parce que je joue en ce moment on aurait
peut être parler d'insécurité partout d'
de pessimisme misère et moi j'ai envie
s'est donné un petit peu d'encouragement
du part de rêve aux jeunes en leur
disant balesi parce que coton je pense
que moi je suis pas une superwoman
quelqu'un de normal et que quand on
arrive on peut aller jusqu'au bout il
suffit de le vouloir
voilà plongés des prières là pendant le
jeu pensé tous les jours et quelques
belles phrases de peggy bouchet que j'ai
noté sait seule la victoire est belle je
trouve ces belles fraises en fait qui
dit qui au départ se dit la seule la
victoire est jolie s'était malinowski
amarin qu'il arrive il ya une différence
entre vivre et exister et votre devise
osé toujours céder parfois renoncer
jamais pas mal l'avenir c'est quoi alors
voilà c'est un petit peu trop tôt
campement pacifique au nom ali l'aviron
ses vinyles à lyon oui des fois
l'atlantique c'est toujours pas de
fiancé l'a vécue dans sa vie privée
un dirai ça ma sphère du cinoche élancé
manière dont ça va peut-être s'arranger
non je lance des appels et bronze et là
croyez moi qu'elle mangeait une
ouverture au sérieux ben je vais lancer
un ami c'est un appel parler votre
caméra on se croit qu'ils nient ce délit
oui exactement vous êtes blonde me voilà
tu m'as tu as le modèle accepté voilà
c'est ça top model accepté on n'a aucune
tumeur mais bon je suis assez grande
pour du bruit tout ça justement à voir
sinon je me fais moi je tape âmes non
mais je préfère traiter en direct
alors d'accord il pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu